it's like you just don't know what
you're gonna get well then then you
should learn to pick better but this is
something you can say learn to pick
better but everyone's good at lying
everyone's good at deceiving everyone's
good at pretending to be something
they're not but also too we do not so
are women no but I'm not saying just
yeah but I'm saying in both parties
everyone can like everyone can do
whatever but the problem is we don't
have actual conversations to decipher
what kind of person you're right but
we've said that we've said this uh
multiple times in different ways it's
about core values if you are talking to
a man and your first questions aren't
about you know your core values why why
would this progress it's true you know
and I think holding accountability for
your part to play in The Suffering in a
relationship it takes two tatangers they
say right so it's a contribution from
both sides nobody's perfect we
understand that
um but at the same time you do not want
to to take the victim position because
then that means that you're not taking
accountability for your part to play in
the problem
sometimes sorry quick thing when there
are situations where no one's taking
accountability that's why it's so
helpful to go for these like mediations
and counseling because someone on
outside can look into what you are blind
yeah but what what my point is if you
if you discern this early on you will
not have to go through all of that but
sometimes I feel people
choose like they can see something but
they choose to like turn a blind eye to
it before yeah
for a period of time because you know
how like women I feel like a lot of
women see a man as
uh not his purpose potential potential
yes you meet someone to see them
potential you don't meet someone to be
like oh I see you you what am I gonna
like they say about you you're sorry
you're just to say what my point is is
when you have a conversation with this
potential future you know your man
you have to ask questions that discern
the information you need to know if you
don't know what the man's goals are from
early on why are you here if you don't
know if the man wants a family why are
you here if you don't understand his
family Dynamic why are you here do you
get me what what relationships he
already has established will show you a
lot about the type of man he is
um I just wanted to say and with that
information you can make a decision that
will be beneficial to both parties
well and you attract what you are so if
you keep attracting toxic people
something about is toxic like you're the
only common denominator in every single
situation you're in you can't run from
yourself
um sorry you cannot just you say hello
you're saying that like you have to
discern by asking what are their goals
what their this what are they that right
people's
decisions change things influence them
and change so you might meet someone and
they might say oh I want children by
this age they get to let's just say they
say they want children by 30. they get
to 25 and they're like actually I want
to live my life a bit more no I don't
want children so you've been with them
for five years thinking like okay we're
gonna get to a stage where we're gonna
have kids we're gonna do this we're
gonna do that and then it changes or it
might be like it might be like business
goals for example and then you might be
supporting them you might be being
submissive being there for them and then
that business idea changes but then when
you when say for example I'm saying that
but I feel like the response is going to
be then you pick the wrong man and you
should have looked better but you've got
told what you got told so what I would
say to you then is I'd go all right
after two years have I married you have
I put an engagement ring on you or have
I told you in five years time this is
where my business is going to be and
this is when I want to start looking at
possibly being serious with you but
that's what I'm saying those are the
things that you might ask and they might
answer correctly and you will believe it
yeah so if I've answered correctly right
let's just say for the two years
engagement I haven't done that
um but I'm still talking about I'm I'm
not in financially secure position I
haven't done the two-year thing are you
still sticking with me for the five year
thing so you're saying that like I'm
saying there was red flags before that
you ignored because there was other
goals that you wanted to I said that was
going to reach and I'm saying at that
moment you've made a choice to stick
with me so all the consequences that
come from that choice
are essentially your own fault and it's
it's the red flags that you've ignored
because you've seen the potential or the
things that I've said I'm going to do
but prior to that there was probably on
the date I said oh yo we'll meet for
eight o'clock I've come at 10. there was
probably the small white flags you might
call them but they were red flags from
the jump that showed my character
and it's those things that you will
ignore because you're seeing the
potential and also wanting to do it all
over again because that's another Factor
as well speaking to the right oh that's
another Factor as well of having to do
that all over again imagine you're on a
three-year relationship and then now you
break up and whatnot and you have to do
that all over again before you know it
you reach 30 and then you get and then
you're valued well but that's that's
because women don't date intentionally
like a lot of times we don't from our
early 20s say I'm dating for marriage if
you're not dating for marriage like be
on with it be done we don't do that and
then later when we waste a couple years
and bring it up down the road and he
doesn't put a ring on it then we waste
half our 20s and we're confused to say
is it is really confusing
yeah but I don't I don't think it's
confusing at all I think men generally
are pretty honest about what they want
and if they're not their actions show
pretty early what their intentions are I
think women we just get attached and we
don't listen but would you know say men
because you know how that is a men are a
bit more less mature than women at a
certain point so would you not say that
from let's say
early late teens to Mid
20s they're just free ball in it they're
going with whatever the vibe is we could
choose an older guy okay an older guy
now for him he's got
he probably has things set he's probably
he has goals like he knows like
I want this this and this and I can't
lie like that's very attractive because
it shows that like you're
straightforward like you're not playing
about you know what you want you're
gonna get what you want but it does it
doesn't necessarily mean you've got a
time frame you just know you want that
and some women have to understand that
one of mine is when a mind is set is set
so you're either with it or
you know basically well I mean let's
let's let me look right now so the
average age
our first marriage
UK let's see average age of first
marriage in the UK
um is 31. wow so I mean like you could
look at 21 you could look at guys that
are 31. that's not that that's not about
age Gap 10 years that's that's perfect
yeah
what well I don't know about that age
guys
I can't hear you I said oh me and this
might can you hear yourself yeah yeah
okay I think you gotta you gotta push it
yeah yeah I can't hear myself
hold on I think the wire maybe is
stopping it from what I'm saying is five
to ten years age Gap is all right
so I think that's I mean I would do up
to 20 to be honest
oh it's because of this whole
modernization and how women are changing
because if a girl's now in her 20s
depending if if culture and religion is
into a factor that's different but if
it's not
she just wants to
see everything be everywhere like have
fun live her life because that's what's
Seen On TV that's what's seen on social
media so it's like marriage is not a
thing to them at that time
or settling down at that time to go I
mean because you do have these people
that are in relationships from 18
they're like I'll be my man for like
three four years you're thinking how old
are you like oh yeah I'm only 22. you're
thinking uh yeah so when are you two
gonna break off and then wake up again
like when I say break up when are you
gonna separate from each other
get to
see the world do whatever and then come
back again if that makes sense because
if relationships I feel like
long-term relationships have a gap for a
little bit if that makes sense because
of how much you change so if you don't
take a break
it's just going to be a continuous cycle
and then eventually just gonna blow up
and be like like you want to break up
for a little bit and then get back
together you like separate and I I don't
think that's really unhealthy I'll
explain to you saying it like that
sounds wild no it's not there's no way
you you could say that it wouldn't sound
wild and I'll explain to you why
whoever initiates the breakup right will
have an idea that you're an Expendable
asset as in like I can break up with you
and then get back with you with no
repercussions because I can call it a
break hmm
I went through this in my first
relationship where I had no clue what
was going on like I took a break yeah
because my partner felt like they needed
that and I said cool that's fine and
then I learned that at that moment like
you become an Expendable asset because
that person can take a break or break up
with you and get back with you whenever
they want yeah and then that's an
emotional toll for you
because they don't value it as an asset
they don't think they can lose you it's
only when you can say boom we're done we
we we're not getting back together and
this is done like you can see it like
that or you can see it as like
you need to separate from one another to
have an understanding that yo this is
actually the person for me because you
might have a break for four years maybe
I mean because I do the reason why I say
that is because I do see relationships
where they were dating when they were
younger they've taken a break and
they've come back together again when
they're much older and much experienced
with life and everything okay so that's
very much a woman's point of view
because like basically you're saying to
a man let me go get ran through let me
go rack up more let me go four years
you're gonna sleep with somebody okay if
you're having sex with him you're gonna
sleep with somebody so you're saying
let's take a break let me go acquire
more damage let me go get more bodies
and let me come back to you later
and ask for a higher price which is a
ring no but you'll seen it from a man's
point of view you're seeing it from a
woman's point of view like ish Am I
Wrong this facts yeah
I'm not saying you're putting views
wrong I'm just saying this is your point
of view and I'm talking from a man's
point of view and so is Paul
she's only telling you what men are
thinking and essentially you as a woman
if you want to acquire a man you need to
understand what I'm thinking
maybe maybe it might not even be
important to you I don't know but like
like if you're looking to get a man then
as long as you can make a decision and
that's up to you completely but at least
you have the knowledge to understand
okay this is what I feel
but this is what he thinks this is what
men think so
if you've been with someone for a while
yep and you can feel yourself like not
feeling attracted to them yep but you
still love them so you're gonna carry on
staying with that person yeah I mean
okay if you because you're showing a man
what is he going to get as a wife
that's what that's what you're you're
applying for so if if I'm dating a man
and I'm I'm applying wait wait so if I'm
dating a man I'm applying for the
position of a wife because I wouldn't
spend my time or date a guy that I
wouldn't marry just me personally like
why why are we wasting my time so that's
the position I'm applying for so I'm
showing him that when times get tough
and I get bored I'm Gonna Leave
why would a man want a wife a girl that
when she's not happy she's just gonna
leave when things get tough because
you're going to live till you're 90.
there's going to be years where you
don't really like each other and so this
is men's problem with modern women
they're selfish because we put our
happiness Above All Else
but I'm asking in the sense of
if you are with someone and you can feel
it like okay as a man you're with a
woman for a long time but you can feel
yourself detaching yourself from her but
you still love her yeah are you still
gonna stay yeah
okay because at that moment I'd
understand that there's more to it than
just my feelings or at that current
moment in time because if you're telling
me at that moment I'm not feeling it
cool what happens in two months time no
but you can feel the relationship
deterring like you just you can feel
yourself you know what I'm about to do
something Unfaithful yeah oh gosh like
God forbid but if I'm about to do
something Unfaithful which
yeah I'd I'd leave like I would never
want to do that to someone you know I
mean okay so yeah if I leave but here's
as a man of principle
if I leave I'm not coming back because
my my mindset is what
took it so far that I couldn't have
worked hard to make sure we didn't break
up what if you entered something
prematurely
wait all right if I explain that how
would I enter something prematurely
you met a girl now yeah and
maybe you're younger yeah okay maybe
it's because you're younger
okay now dating her and whatnot what not
and you're like oh
I would have known within the first I'd
say 15 seconds whether
I I want to take it seriously or I this
is a casual thing just just to let you
know
like that's whether I want to I I would
then find out through character that
maybe she's not a serious candidate
maybe she is but within the first 15
seconds I know
okay so there's no premature thing maybe
I Amanda might be lying saying oh like
there is like I I couldn't tell I don't
know what it is they're lying they knew
exactly what it was from the jump they
know within 15 seconds the first
conversation whether they are feeling
you or whether this is a
yeah I'm just trying to smash and move
on so can I just sure
um
I feel like from this conversation and
previous conversation it feels like even
pal said that we are applying for role
as a wife
even though there can be women of high
value even they have to apply for the
role so everything revolves around the
man and without the man you can't do
nothing because it's impossible to be
independent but
um
it just feels like
if you're if you're a certain type of
way if you're modern whatever you want
to call it then
you're not going to find a
foreign
because it's not necessarily just about
money because my def the definition of
high value that I've got is about money
but for me obviously the high value is
something completely different but then
you guys would say that's beta no